hi I'm Jonathan Levin
I'm the incoming Dean of the Stanford
Graduate School of Business I can't wait
to get started in this new position I'm
going to do so later this summer by
meeting with members of the GSB
community and hearing about what they
perceive to be the opportunities and the
challenges facing the school some of our
students already have questions let's
get started what are you most excited
about in this role there's so many
reasons to be excited about this new
position first of all the GSB is just
unparalleled in the excellence of its
faculty students staff and alumni the
faculty here are exceptional
intellectual thought leaders the
students of the GSB brings so much
passion and energy and talent to the
University and really impressed by the
dedication and the commitment of the
alumni the alumni are a tremendous asset
to the GSB I've had the opportunity at
Stanford to be a researcher to be a
teacher and to be an advisor and a
consultant to companies here in Silicon
Valley and elsewhere I'm so excited to
be in a position where I get to bring
all these different experiences together
and get to work with members of the GSB
community and the larger University who
I admire so much what role do you see
the GSB playing in the larger Stanford
University Stanford has enjoyed such an
extraordinary 15 years under the
leadership of John Hennessy and John
etchemendy I'm really excited to work
with Stanford's new president Merck
Cassie Levine to find ways for the GSB
to cooperate with the larger University
and to make the entire campus even
stronger GSB already has connections
with all of Stanford's other schools I
experienced it myself
when I was in the economics department
we had close partnerships with many of
the students and faculty here at the GSB
I'm confident we can find so many more
of those opportunities what is the
legacy you hope to leave behind as
Stanford GSB what is remarkable about
the GSB is that it excels in both the
educational experience that it offers to
its students and in the scholarship of
its faculty and these two things come
together to help the school achieve its
mission of changing lives changing
organizations and changing the world if
I could choose one thing to leave behind
as my legacy at the GSB it would be to
strengthen the school in both of these
dimensions what does diversity mean to
you and how do you intend on growing
diversity at the GSB the GSB already is
making strides to become a more diverse
place the current graduating class of
MBAs is over 40 percent women that's up
from the mid-30s just a few years ago
the current graduating class also has
over 40 percent international students
and 23 percent u.s. minorities the GSB
also has launched a research Fellows
program with the goal of preparing women
and minority students to the Graduate
researchers and eventually scholars and
academics we also didn't make sure that
students after they leave the university
are supportive so that our women and
minority students can be successful all
the way from the classroom into
boardrooms and other positions of
leadership what's your favorite place in
the world well I really love being at in
outdoors and in the wilderness when I
first moved to California one of my
favorite things to do was to go out on
the weekends drive up to the Sierra
Nevadas and go out climbing or hiking or
whit water kayaking I once carried my
kayak up to the top of Mount Whitney and
kayak down the west side of the mountain
on the Kern River now it is we have
three kids
most of our adventures are a little bit
more local what matters most to you and
why it matters to me
to be part of an institution that is
having a positive impact on people's
lives
Stanford is such a remarkable place in
its innovation and in its contribution
to educating the world's future leaders
it's such a privilege to be part of this
community
and to have this leadership opportunity